au sommaire de cette édition du 6
septembre je vous l'avais dit nous
allons parler de sport du sport
paralympique Florence Sirault gocio est
engagé en tennis de table fauteuil avec
le club de tennis de table d'Élancourt
son entraîneur lui est déjà revenu de
Londres vous êtes revenu il y a quelques
jours il y a 2 jours merci d'être déjà
avec nous sur le plateau dites nous
comment ça se passe sur place pour elle
là-bas elle est encore là-bas il y a
encore des épreuves tout à fait donc il
y avait les épreuves en individuel et
maintenant il y a des épreuves par
équipe donc elle est toujours au village
olympique toujours à Londres qui ont les
épreuves les épreuves par équipe ont
débuté aujourd'hui et ensuite ça va
aller jusqu'au 8 et à partir du 9 ça
sera la cérémonie de clôture quel bilan
alors sur ces épreuves individuelles
déjà qui ont eu lieu plutôt positif donc
elle gagne son premier match sur une
Irlandaise qui est numéro 11 mondial
Florence actuellement et numéro 7
ensuite elle est arrivée donc en quart
de finale
et donc elle a joué sur une sur une
italienne qui est classée numéro 2
mondial donc là tout de suite c'est plus
compliqué mais elle a réussi à accrocher
à aller jusqu'à la belle c'est la
première fois qu'elle le fait de toute
sa carrière donc non c'est c'est une
belle compétition c'était c'était pas
forcément évident pour elle donc c'est
bien et puis on va essayer maintenant
d'aller voir au Brésil vous allez voir
justement sur des images à
l'entraînement nous l'avions suivi il y
a quelques années justement est-ce que
son niveau a progressé comment elle
s'est développée les images qu'on a vu
c'était lors d'un entraînement c'était
en 2008 oui alors depuis 2008 il y a eu
une bonne évolution
tout d'abord la fée médaille médaille de
bronze au championnats d'Europe donc en
2011 donc sa première médaille sur une
compétition importante au niveau du
tennis de table donc uniquement ça ça
progresse ça évolue c'est sûr qu'une
petite médaille allons aura été
objectivement vous êtes son entraîneur
vous avez vu évoluer les autres joueuses
bah c'était vraiment possible quand on
voit qu'elle fait qui perd à la belle 3
à deux sur la numéro 2 mondial c'était
c'était oui non c'était vraiment
possible c'était une médaille un podium
aurait pu être vraiment pu être
envisageable alors vous étiez sur
l'ombre est-ce qu'il y a un engouement
véritablement autour des Jeux
paralympiques comment ça se passe
justement aussi pour les pour les
athlètes est-ce qu'il y a du monde dans
les tribunes on parle des jeux les plus
en tout cas qui ont attiré le plus de
monde plus de 2 millions et demi de
billets vendus c'est alors que c'est un
million 8 il y a voilà donc c'était
vraiment très très impressionnant c'est
que même pour les Jeux paralympiques
c'était vraiment complet c'était
vraiment complet donc c'est c'est
vraiment bien on sent que on sent que on
dit sport se développe de plus en plus
qui de plus en plus de bénévoles et de
personnes qui ont envie de d'aider dans
cette dans ce secteur là donc c'est
c'est vraiment bien que que sur les jeux
sur une compétition comme ça on se rend
compte que ça soit fermé quoi il est
vraiment c'était vraiment plein plein à
craquer donc c'était vraiment sympa et
est-ce qu'il y a un décalage avec ce qui
se passe en France alors en France on
sent pas cet engouement voilà sans
parler de la médiatisation aussi par
exemple sur la médiatisation c'est vrai
que sur les sur le peu de temps où je
suis resté à Londres tous les jours tous
les journaux il y avait trois quatre
pages sur les sur les Jeux paralympiques
on est resté énormément sur les sur les
Anglais bien évidemment mais il y avait
vraiment une grosse médiatisation dessus
que ce soit les journaux les tous les
jours à la télé on en entendait parler
donc non il y a vraiment un
développement qui a été fait là-dessus
et je pense encore plus pendant grâce à
l'organisation des Jeux mais on sent
qu'il y a quand même des choses qui ont
été faites là-bas Jean-Philippe Mallet
c'est pas le rôle du service public
France Télévisions par exemple devrait
pas diffuser plus c'est Jeux
paralympiques c'était pas du tout prévu
il y a eu un effort c'est comme ça que
ça a été présenté par les dirigeants de
la chaîne avec finalement un magazine
tous les soirs d'une cinquantaine de
minutes au départ il y avait une
couverture encore plus petite un qui
était prévue sur l'événement c'est vrai
je partage votre votre questionnement
mais en la matière comme on dort je
pense que le service public de la
télévision doit faire des efforts de
qualité d'exigence et effectivement ce
qui compte c'est la performance si on
voit qu'il y a il y a un dépassement de
soi quoi je suis chez ses athlètes quoi
tout ça ça fait partie des discussions
aussi au sein du gouvernement bien sûr
financement de France Télé un problème
de qualité bien sûr vous avez raison un
problème de qualité du service public
télé qu'il faut qu'il faut réhabiliter
les dossiers sont chargés vous allez
j'imagine nous suivre tout ça en tout
cas nous sommes allés demander aux cinq
continents si ça continue à s'il suivait
ses Jeux paralympiques même s'ils sont
assez peu médiatisés est-ce qu'ils
suivent un petit peu les performances
des athlètes
alors non parce que c'est trop tard le
soir mais je regarde les flashs dans la
journée oui mais il y en a pas assez et
pourquoi parce que je suis moi-même
handicapé et c'est vrai que je trouve
qu'ils font des prouesses des choses
extraordinaires alors non je ne les suis
pas et c'est très dommage parce qu'en
fait ils sont pas retransmis ou très
tard donc du coup on ne les voit pas et
c'est assez dramatique parce qu'on a mis
vachement en avant les les gens
nous handicapés et
là on les voit pas il faudrait aussi les
mettre beaucoup plus tôt oui alors oui
parce qu'il y a pas de raison que les
que les gens qui soient handicapés n'est
pas les mêmes la même attention du
public en fait que les gens qui sont
valides un petit peu parce que j'ai une
personne que je connais qui les a déjà
fait personnellement et qui a été suivi
d'un accident j'ai regardé un petit peu
mais c'est vrai que c'est pas diffusé
sur beaucoup de chaînes donc c'est pas
c'est pas facile oui je les suis parce
que je trouve que c'est c'est jeune et
aussi sont ces des jeunes il faut un
effort extraordinaire il nous montre ils
sont un modèle pour nous grâce à
l'effort qu'il voilà
il y a une véritable attente les gens
ont envie que ce soit médiatisés ils ont
envie de suivre et même si c'est assez
peu médiatisé finalement et ils suivent
il y a internet aussi pour regarder un
petit peu tout ça combien d'athlètes qui
sont en situation de handicap sont
suivies par le club de tennis de table
d'Élancourt c'est la seule alors donc on
a créé donc une section handisport dans
le club donc en 2011
Florence entraînait déjà depuis 2010
mais on a on a vraiment lancé
l'affiliation à la à la Fédération
Française Handisport donc en 2011 donc
ça a commencé avec Florence et puis à
force de travail puis le milieu du donc
j'annule de table c'est assez petit
encore plus dans le milieu du handisport
donc du coup tout le monde se connaît et
donc c'est vrai que ça fait un peu de
entre guillemets un peu de publicité
donc du coup il y a d'autres personnes
qui ont voulu venir sur le club
d'Élancourt pour savoir tiens comment ça
se passe il y a des entraînements
spécifiques handisport et donc oui là ça
évolue maintenant on passe à et vous
avez tout matériel nécessaire pour pas
pouvoir s'inscrire justement tout à fait
donc il y a le matériel moi après je
joue flor c'est donc étant été
traplégique en fauteuil roulant moi
quand je quand je m'entraîne avec elle
je joue en fauteuil roulant pour être
dans les mêmes conditions appartient au
club le club a investi donc il y a
diverses matériels pédagogiques donc
c'est non c'est ça évolue c'est c'est
pas évident ça prend du temps mais ça
évolue petit à petit donc c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment intéressant on voit que
c'est vraiment un engouement qu'ils ont
une vraie volonté de se dépasser donc ça
c'est vraiment enrichissant que ça soit
pour même pour moi en tant que en tant
que cadre technique c'est c'est vraiment
enrichissant dernière question
concernant Florence Serreau justement
est-ce qu'elle pense déjà aux prochaines
olympiades bah tout à fait m'a fait une
confidence justement pendant les jeux où
elle n'était pas forcément sûre de
vouloir de vouloir continuer ou d'avoir
la motivation effectivement avec ce
qu'elle a fait là pendant les Jeux ça ça
a été une libération et donc on va
décrocher cette médaille c'est pas là ça
sera exactement
passé sur ce plateau un petit peu les
performances donc de Florence sirop
gossu on va quitter le plateau quelques
instants Yvelines tourisme a lancé ce
mardi soir depuis le Petit Trianon à
Versailles l'opération paroles de
jardinier du 8 au 30 septembre 46 sites
y participent à inviter d'honneur
Gonzague Saint-Bris écrivain journaliste
historien et Catherine zulato elle l'a
rencontré et lui a demandé et qu'elle
était le jardin de ses rêves
alors le jardin de mes rêves c'est celui
qui est au bout du jardin parce que le
principe du jardin romantique c'est que
tout vous permet d'accéder par les yeux
à un endroit plus loin où est le bonheur
et c'est ça le jardin romantique c'est
que le bonheur est toujours un peu plus
loin mais j'aime aussi beaucoup celui
qu'on appelait le bonhomme le nôtre
parce que c'était un être qui en fait
réglait des problèmes en faisant des
miracles c'est à dire que Versailles
c'est des marais qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire avec tous ces marées et le nous
dit on va faire un canal les Tuileries
c'est un château dans Paris et que faire
pour donner un sens aux Tuileries et
bien on va inventer une avenue qui
s'appelle les Champs-Élysées elle est
longue cette avenue parce qu'elle part
de la place autrefois royal à place d'un
Concorde et elle va au-delà de la
défense pour s'arrêter
à la croix de Noailles dans le dans la
forêt de Saint-Germain donc le nôtre
c'est le type à qui on dit il y a un
truc qu'est-ce qu'on va faire il trouve
toujours la solution